merci d'avoir accepté j'ai un boulot
pour nous bonsoir général si vous
vouliez avoir la gentillesse de virer
votre tu d'assassins dit si on vous en
serais très reconnaissant
james ford le général raïl aurait bien
besoin de vos conseils bon bah je crois
qu'on s'est tous dit alors merci merci
pour le vert
il est à 4 heures l'équipage du vendeur
a signalé un premier contact passe moi
le commandant de l'alliance ya une
urgence je viens aux rapports qu'ont
signaler un incident de nature un fait
ils les ont pris pour cible
tu crois vraiment être de taille à
accomplir cette mission
[Musique]
propose moi la question si tu n'oses je
déclare officiellement lancé l'opération
cosmique si votre équipement
a beau casting devoyault vous avez mis
sur pied tu n'as jamais fait son
cantique
j'aurais dû rester au bar
[Musique]
si vous voulez la paix préparer la
guerre la dernière fois que j'ai entendu
cette maxime c'est quand elle vous a
servi d'excusé pour balancer une bande
ku sur 70 millions d'êtres vivants
notre premier réflexe à ce premier
contact a été de faire appel au général
sanguinaire
c'est un va-t-en-guerre on va frapper
fort avant même que cette guerre ne
commence
allez on tire une civilisation n'est ni
plus ni moins qu'à repêchés entre le
coaching
préparez une bande ku
et dans l'éventualité d'un premier
contact l'humanité doit frapper la
première en vue d'assurer la survie et
la continuité du milliardaire
on va quand même pas 100 personnes ne va
se rendre